à l'issue du conseil d'administration
certains visages sont crispés
le pôle de la martinique se sentent en
danger depuis que le président de
l'université des antilles a décidé de
procéder à un rééquilibrage des postes
et des crédits une répartition des
moyens juste et respectueuse de la loi
selon le vice président du pôle bois de
loupe il y a eu un fort déséquilibre qui
a été fait pendant les trois positions
c'est surtout la dernière présidence
budget doit être réparé antilles et b en
fonction du nombre d'étudiants messieurs
de l'euro au guichet
cette répartition des enveloppes
budgétaires s'effectue en fonction de
critères précis en effet comme le nombre
d'étudiants ils sont 2000 de plus en
guadeloupe mais aussi de leurs coûts
sans compter le nombre de chercheurs
produisent en est là encore la
guadeloupe en enregistrent davantage le
président n'a n'est pas là pour empêcher
à un paul de fonctionner on va pas
empêcher au vice-président d'ouvrir des
postes mais il ya des postes vacants et
à des postes vacants sur les deux pôles
eh ben on va récupérer la masse
salariale de ces postes vacants de
manière à faire un équilibrage et cet
équilibre a se fera sur une dizaine
d'années la réunion plutôt sous tension
a donc pris l'alluré d'une mise au point
et les représentants du pôle martinique
et au final ont plaidé pour davantage de
dialogue dès 2019
il était prévu que pas moins de six cent
mille euros de masse salariale soit
rétrocédée aux paul cuenca donc nous
devons rentrer dans un véritable
dialogue politique parce qu'il ya à
prendre en considération
quand on parle de rééquilibrage est bien
de rééquilibrage nécessaire sur chacun
des deux pôles et nous l'avons bien dit
aujourd'hui un épisode qui révèle toute
la fragilité de cette unité
universitaire et qui fait remonter à la
surface de vieilles rivalités entre
martinique et guadeloupe